bonsoir beau gosse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à toutes et à tous pour cette
journée de la femme on n'est pas violent
[Applaudissements]
incendie à sa mission commence à malabo
t il y aura du beau gosse il y aura des
femmes
il y aura des femmes mi figue mi raisin
mais je ne peux pas le regard non mais
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
le problème jean michel seydoux crédible
mais sans rigoler on dirait didier
bourdon dans le sketch télématique
vraiment heureux dit franchement on
dirait un gloss que j'aurais plus dragué
quoi mais j'ai l'impression que vous on
peut baser en fait toujours basculé
c'est vrai là et on peut toujours
basculé mais pas moi merci on aime bien
aussi gilbert be alive ans
[Applaudissements]
je lance tout de suite a acheté à grasse
raddad l'angoissé on fait comme si je
rentrais dans un bar s'il vous plaît
bonsoir beau gosse
c'est venu tout seul oui mon enfant oui
sorcière de blanche neige
non moi je suis je suis venue seule mais
je vais repartir ça je pense en avoir
mon chéri ch vous vous trouvez philippe
ans parce que ça a été très très bien
fait assez crédible et vous vous à côté
vraiment isabelle on dirait que vous
êtes la patronne
bah oui allez-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on se calme
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
canonné
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]